kim kardashian and kanye west have
called it quits after
six years of marriage the couple share
four children together
in december a source told e.t kim and
kanye were having difficulties in their
marriage but were both
doing their best kim's family will
support her in
any decision she makes but she feels
that the most important thing to
recognize before making any choice is
realizing what's best for the kids
herself kanye and the rest of the family
essentially in that order
the decision to go separate ways comes
after a string of highly publicized
issues between the couple in 2020.
on july 4 kanye announced he was running
for president during a rally in south
carolina a few weeks later the rapper
delivered a speech
saying he and kim discussed an abortion
before having their daughter
north so even if my wife were to divorce
me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to a source told
et at the time that kim was upset over
the speech adding quote
she knows this is something north will
see when she gets older and that's
heartbreaking
on the night of july 20th kanye fired
off a series of since-deleted tweets
aimed at kim
and her mother kris jenner claiming they
were trying to lock him up
a few days later kim addressed the
struggles kanye faces with bipolar
disorder
writing in part anyone who has this or
has a loved one in their life who does
knows how incredibly complicated and
painful it is to understand
i kindly ask that the media and public
give us the compassion and empathy
that is needed so that we can get
through this i've seen him go through
a lot and he's just the most genuine
person and you know he might say things
that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind
it but i always know his heart in may
kim and kanye came together to celebrate
their sixth wedding anniversary
kim captioned the post six years down
forever to go
until the end the former couple publicly
stood by each other's sides through
ups and downs throughout the years i
mean we love each other's opinions and
we definitely rely on each other for
each other's opinions when we're working
on things
the two met back in 2003 and remained
friends until they started dating in
2012.
him and i have been best friends for a
really long time and just been in each
other's lives and known each other for a
long time
and i can honestly say
i think that's just a really good
foundation for a good relationship
by december 2012 kanye announced kim was
pregnant during a concert in atlantic
city
referring to kim as his baby mama kim
later confirmed the news on twitter
okay so we are officially going okay
your dad is on a plane
[Music]
in june 2013 they welcomed their first
child daughter
north she definitely has kanye's
outgoing personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend
and then she's also really calm and
sweet like me sometimes
kanye proposed to kim in front of her
family and friends in october 2013.
he rented out the entire san francisco
baseball stadium
and proposed to her on her 33rd birthday
with a stunning
15 carat diamond ring that was the
craziest
experience of my life in such an amazing
time do you think it was happening that
night
absolutely not i had no idea i thought
we were having dinner and then when we
walked out i thought it was just going
to be dinner
um out on the baseball field i still had
no idea he was going to propose it was
so surreal
in may 2014 the two were married in
florence italy
it's the best feeling to have your own
family and kids and
it's the best in december 2015 they
welcomed their second
child son saint
i don't know why i'm crying i've talked
about this before nearly one year later
in october 2016
kim was tied up and robbed at gunpoint
in paris
they tried it the last trip but kanye
was there and they were too
scared and then they said they saw on
social media
that i had this huge new ring just tell
them i have children like i have babies
i have a husband i have a family like i
have to get home
tell them take anything i'll never say
like i saw them like take everything
the robbery had a huge impact on kanye
kanye said the robbery was a major
factor that caused him to suffer a
breakdown a month later
what's wrong
[Music]
don't scare me please what's going on
[Music]
like i can't
a source told et at the time that kim
was dedicated and devoted to kanye more
than
ever following his hospitalization
soon the two would continue expanding
their family
welcoming their third child daughter
chicago via surrogate in january 2018
and in may 2019 kim and kanye welcomed
their son
psalm completing their family kanye and
i work really hard
and i hope that's motivating for them
and just to find their own path
that same month the two renewed their
vows in a private ceremony
what does it mean to you to have this
family now kanye and you look at your
daughter you look at your wife and
how has that fulfilled your life it's
given me a whole perspective an
understanding of what to work for
what to live for and an understanding of
how other families
you know operate put things in
perspective and it does make you
just you know like everyone goes through
this and you have no idea what it really
is like until you go through it yourself
but it's the best feeling to have
your own family and kids and it's the
[Music]
best
you